they said I had to look and they also
said they said Brad would often say you
know say his joke was that I would
comment you know I didn't hear anything
you were saying but while you were
talking and then I would say my idea uh
and and so I just wrote that character
and everybody's like oh he's such a
great villain and I was like interesting
in some ways McKay is Cooper and David
Huer obviously talks about how he felt
that actually was a morphing of between
Brad Wright and Robert Cooper and you
know Brad Wright wrote a lot of the
characters so of course it would be and
would reflect elements of his own
personality in there perhaps but also
Brad W has talked a lot about how he
would watch actors and that he would try
to bring a lot of their own mannerisms
into a character and let's be honest
David huet was McKay I've watched David
huet in interviews Etc and on his
podcasts and on his streaming for years
and every so often he sounds like McKay